oh ja
[Musik]
in der vorwärts- und gerätschaften von
geräte waffen verkauft seine kurz
überprüft und kurzer check
[Musik]
als frau machen statt einfach überhaupt
keinen unterschied weil besatzung des
besatzung und bei der besetzung kann
jeder mit zum arbeiten war hoch
[Musik]
die aufgaben von einem paten zugs
konnten ist eigentlich dass man den zug
führt den zug beieinander heute
motiviert war und das funktioniert von
rom eine chance
[Musik]
und ausländergesetz techniken müssen wir
in den raum stellungen beziehung und von
bw aasee und dies zu tod
[Musik]
mit 100 betriebe schaden mit der
ungarischen
[Musik]
motorraum abdeckung abheben krank war
das faszinierend der mechaniker tube
nichts zu essen am ende des tages das
gerät repariert hat
[Musik]
euro belassen
ich wollte eigentlich schon immer zum
bundesheer gehen träume entscheidung
wirklich überhaupt gar nicht
man muss immer wachsam sein weil das
können wir vielleicht ein normaler
einsatz wäre wie das leben kosten einer
besatzung
pater 2 gewonnen
ich freue mich jedes mal wenn ihr
richtig zu finden und die das schießen
ich habe das gerät wirklich lieben
gelernt